[Music]
kakariko village is a familiar name in
the zelda series
a reoccurring landmark in hyrule's
landscape though different in each
installment
from a japanese-style shika village
hylian farming settlement to something
straight out of a classic western but by
far my favorite rendition of this iconic
village is the one found in ocarina of
time
a quaint little town at the foot of
another famous landmark the active
volcano death mountain
home of the gorons but it's not the town
itself that makes this place so
interesting
it only has a small handful of buildings
and inhabitants most of which don't play
a key role in the story
and yet this seemingly peaceful little
village holds a plethora of some of
ocarina of time's biggest mysteries
the cursed family living inside the
skulltula house the origins of the song
of storms haunted graveyard
and of course a woman who is allergic to
cuckoos yet choosing cocoa farming
as her profession why would you do that
seriously that's like a peanut farmer
with a severe peanut allergy
but the biggest mysteries about kakriko
village are not the ones found on the
surface but rather
that which lies underneath by far the
craziest and most unsettling aspect
about kakariko
is that right below the feet of its
unsuspecting settlers lies a vast
network of tunnels
caves rooms and corridors which when put
together are way bigger than the actual
village that stands above ground
most famous are of course the shadow
temple and its sister mini dungeon the
bottom of the well
two locations which on their own already
hold a lot of mystery
especially because of their gruesome
haunting atmospheres and aesthetics
hints of torture imprisonment mass
graves and even the living dead are a
common sight down here
the more you uncover about kakariko
village the more you realize that there
is something
seriously wrong with this place and
today we will attempt to get a bigger
picture
to see why and how this part of hyrule
came to be
so wretched together with nintendo black
crisis we will cover the construction of
kakariko's underground its ties to the
shika dark
history implications of spirit magic how
this all ultimately led to some eerie
and
unforeseen consequences and even a
possible connection to breath of the
wild and its upcoming sequel
there is a lot to dissect so join us as
we take a deep dive into the curious
case of
kakrico village
[Music]
although kakariko village is a hylian
settlement by the time the events of the
game take place
it is told to us that in the past it was
predominantly a chica village instead
a place where they lived and operated
from during one of hyrule's most brutal
conflicts
the hyrulian civil war the sheikah
basically served as a sort of secret
police for the kingdom of hyrule
an elusive tribe who operated from the
shadows out of sight from the public eye
on behalf of the royal family by the
time we visit the village in ocarina of
time the conflict has only been resolved
for
about nine years the shika are close to
extinction
with its only known living member being
impa who now serves as princess zelda's
personal caretaker
the rest of the tribe has been laid to
rest in kakariko's graveyard
and the village itself has since become
occupied by hylians
as is often in bloody conflicts all
sides like to think of themselves as the
righteous ones the good guys in the
story
hence the gruesome fate of prisoners of
war are preferably kept
out of public sight and for good reason
i mean from what we can see the stuff
the shika were doing
isn't exactly something you would want
the world to see
obviously the royal family of hyrule had
a reputation to uphold
and signs of such cruelty would stain
that reputation
and this is where kakariko village
allegedly
came into play given their secret of
nature the chica were the perfect
candidates to catch
imprison and dispose of prisoners of war
and their hometown basically became
ground zero for these horrible acts of
war
however to obscure the cruelty carried
out in the name of hyrule's royal family
they either constructed new underground
structures in and around the village
or repurposed those that were already
there before
like the bottom of the well for instance
these structures
such as the aforementioned shadow temple
and bottom of the well
would serve as both prisons torture
sites as well as the final resting place
for the unfortunate souls taken down
here
never to be seen again now this is all
nothing new there have been theories
about these locations and practices for
decades
and most agree that this was indeed the
most likely purpose of these underground
locales
all the evidence seems to point at this
scenario but what it doesn't explain is
exactly how these places
as well as the town above became so ripe
with curses
hauntings and vast amounts of undead
lurking beneath the surface
i mean it's likely that many people died
all over hyrule during the civil war
right so how did kakariko in particular
come to be so
tainted the fact that a lot of people
died here doesn't automatically explain
why they would rise from the grave there
has to be
more to it than that a catalyst which
led up to all of this
it's clear that the chica did quite a
bit of digging in and around kakariko
the shadow temple and bottom of the well
are already pretty extensive but these
are not the only underground sections
found around the village
looking at it from above shows just how
much underground space there is below
this little town
and my best guess would be that these
underground sections were all excavated
and built by the chica around the same
time
given their similar architecture some
may have even been connected at some
point or were at least planned to be
connected but never finished after the
excavations were abandoned
first we have the shadow temple whose
entrance is inside the graveyard we have
the royal family's tomb bordering the
temple
and some of the other smaller chambers
inside some of the graves and one in the
center of town
then we have dumped grave which is a
vast network of man-made corridors and
tunnels snaking underneath the graveyard
and into the village itself
it's safe to assume that this grave was
not dug solely for the purpose of
donpe's final resting place
it's a bit excessive for one person
wouldn't you agree
not to mention we find multiple skeletal
remains here indicating that more than
just one
individual was buried here the crypt
also has frequent dead ends and some of
these tunnels look like they were still
under construction by the time the
project was abandoned all this
ultimately connects directly to the
windmill inside the village
the windmill in turn is capable of
draining the well outside
giving access to the bottom of the well
we even see a schematic of the windmill
hanging on the wall which clearly
depicts that it has mechanisms and
access points extending below ground
and judging from the size comparison the
bottom of the well runs right underneath
the windmill
all this points to these underground
sections being much more connected than
we are visually allowed to see
it's almost like an underground city
existing below kakariko and the
villagers who live out their lives here
don't seem to be aware of the horrors
that lie
only a few meters deep
[Music]
so we have a vast interconnected network
where some horrific events took place
out of sight from the general public
interesting for sure
but it still doesn't explain the
connection of the dead coming back to
life
via cursed and other oddities plaguing
this town
what is perhaps most alarming about
kakariko's underground
is that with the exception of one grave
which leads to a fairy fountain
every single one of these underground
areas houses the reanimated corpses
known as re-deads even the royal
family's tomb is not exempt from this
there's been a lot of debate in the past
about whether or not re-deads are actual
zombies or not
this uncertainty stems from the fact
that smash brothers melee included a
trophy of a re-dead
stating that they were nothing more than
magic animated into hideous
humanoid shapes it even points to
ganondorf being the source of the
redeads
something that is never made clear in
the actual game however we fully side
with celtic on this matter
there's simply too much evidence that
contradicts the melee's trophy
and instead points to redeads indeed
being hyrule's equivalent of
zombies aka the reanimated bodies of the
deceased
and not just magic clay figures so to
speak and if we as
zelda fans had to choose obviously
information from the main game will
always have priority over a trophy in an
unrelated fighting game
we won't get into too many specifics as
that is a theory on its own
but watch celtic's video if you want to
know more
what is important to note however is
that it is quite literally
impossible that re-deads are solely
ganondorf's doing
not only do re-deads exist outside
hyrule in places like termina
far from ganondorf's reach but the
re-deads in the royal family's tomb were
clearly there before
ganondorf's invasion of hyrule you can
access the tomb long before his power
grab
and up until that point ganondorf was
still laying low and playing nice with
hyrule's leadership
the ancient scriptures carved inside the
royal crypt also directly refer to the
living
dead another indication that the
existence of the redeads was a known
fact long ago
perhaps even back when the tomb was
built it stands to reason then that the
same thing goes for
all other re-deads in this general area
the ones in hyrule castle could very
well be placed here by ganondorf
but for the ones in kakariko it just
doesn't add up
not to mention we also have dead hand
gibdos and other undead enemy types
roaming the catacombs of the village as
well
and even bongo bongo seems to share the
same traits of an
undead being how exactly this was all
achieved remains totally unexplained
but there is one particular thing that
in our opinion
could provide a strong hint something
that a lot of these locations have in
[Music]
common
when visiting the bottom of the well the
shadow temple and even the royal
family's tomb
one might stumble upon these pools
containing some weird green substance
not only that but in the case of the
well and the shadow temple they are
found
at the deepest level of the structure
this liquid is harmful to the touch
dealing a quarter heart of damage to
link when he comes into contact with it
what this stuff actually is is never
explained in the game but it's only
found in these parts of hyrule and
nowhere else
now in the zelda series green energy has
always had a connection to
a couple of things two of which being
spirits and magic
and there's an argument to be made that
the two are one in the same
or at the very least deeply connected in
breath of the wild we find the luminous
stones which are said to house the
spirits of the dead the green glow
emitted by the deceased such as king
rome and the champions and of course the
green spiraling energy surrounding the
corpse in the reveal trailer of breath
the wild 2.
the correlation between spirit energy
and magic is made even more clear by the
champion abilities when link frees one
of the deceased champions they will
bestow parts of their soul upon him
giving him access to the magic ability
they possessed in life
we know that magic is important to the
chica even as far back as ocarina of
time the door leading to the shadow
temple requires the use of magic to be
opened the lens of truth which is a
shika artifact literally runs on magic
and in other installments the shika
utilize natural resources such as
crystals and liquids to power their
technology in breath of the wild this is
framed as something scientific but it
might as well be magic in the eyes of
those who don't understand its inner
workings and
even here spirit energy is still
utilized as the divine beasts require
the spirit of a powerful individual to
be operated
again there's clearly a blurred line
between science and magic in this
universe perhaps by the time of breath
the wild these processes were better
understood by the sheikha hence it took
on the shape of science rather than
magic
one thing we know for sure is that
certain individuals can conjure up magic
on their own ganondorf being a good
example though we also have vati
princess zelda herself and more recently
the four champions of the divine beasts
beings who through the power of their
spirit have access to magical abilities
but this seems to be quite rare in
hyrule most ordinary people don't seem
to have the gift of magic
and interestingly enough link himself
too doesn't have magic powers of his own
at least not an ocarina of time he's
only able to use magic because of
certain weapons and artifacts
enchanted objects with magic power which
grant him access to a variety of spells
and attacks
in that sense anyone could potentially
use this magic
if they're in possession of one of these
objects without inherently having powers
themselves
so here's a crazy idea what if during
the excavations below kakrico village
the shika dug
so deep that they accidentally stumbled
upon an underground pocket containing
this green substance which then spilled
out and pulled up inside these caves
and to take it even further that this
was the first discovery of spirit magic
in liquid form
a ghostly substance or fuel seeping
through the cracks of the earth which
allowed for the enchantment of objects
powering technology and other access to
magic for those not naturally gifted it
could have even been the reason why the
hylians gained the upper hand in the
civil war the discovery of destructive
magic
able to be used by common soldiers would
no doubt turn the tides in a war mostly
fought with medieval weaponry however
because this was a new discovery it
stands to reason that this substance
wasn't well understood at the time
after the initial discovery the chica
being the scientists we know them to be
likely studied it extensively
experimented with it and one of the
discoveries made could have been the
effect it had on the dead and it is this
that may have led to the intentional or
unintentional creation of the first
redeads by the looks of it the green
lake found at the bottom of the well
seems to be the location where the
liquid was first discovered as this part
of the well
still looks like a natural cave the
walls are not made of brick nor are they
decorated like they are on the upper
levels
it still genuinely looks like an actual
excavation site there's also signs of
this green energy being studied here
as there are man-made walkways laid
across the lake and we even see hands
sticking out of the pool
an indication that the sheikah may have
attempted to resurrect bodies by
throwing them inside
or even more morbid gone as far as to
throw live prisoners in as a way of
testing the effects
perhaps the sheikah first figured that
this liquid may hold the potential for
eternal life or bringing back loved ones
the royal family could have seen great
potential in this as well which could
explain why the liquid is also found
inside the royal crypt
as opposed to the bottom of the well
where this liquid seems to have pulled
up naturally here it is evenly
distributed into what seems to be
man-made gutters or basins
almost as if it was placed here on
purpose so
could this have been one of the first
attempts to resurrect the deceased
perhaps the kings and queens of old who
had long since passed that or the liquid
along with the redads were purposely
placed here to protect the royal crypt
either way it's pretty messed up if this
is true
it probably didn't take long for the
shika to realize that those brought back
from the dead
had little to no humanity left in them
no cognitive ability at all just
mindless zombies and nothing more even
so hyrule's leadership may have ordered
them to continue creating rededs and
other undead creatures such as deadhand
essentially creating an undead army to
serve the kingdom
heck even bongo bongo could very well be
one of these creations
had this substance only been found in
the bottom of the well in the shadow
temple we could have simply concluded
that it's a byproduct of bongo bongo
something it produces or gives him more
power
but the fact that it's also found in the
royal family's tomb which is built
inside a former chica village makes me
point to them as the ones who messed
around with this stuff and placed it in
some of these locations
after all this stuff is already there
when link enters the tomb as a child
which is before bongo bongo breaks free
anyway while all these attempts at
necromancy were going on the shika
advanced their research into the green
substance further and further
and as crazy as it sounds this ghostly
fluid may have even served as the basis
for the creation of the first
magic potions perhaps at some point they
could have been successful in processing
or refining it into something that is
consumable and harmless to the user
funnily enough this would also fit the
zelda timeline as a whole since
no game taking place prior to ocarina of
time features a magic meter
in some of these installments green
colored potions are present such as the
stamina potion but these don't have any
correlation with magic
later on new waves may have been found
to extract or produce magic potion
without having to dig underground
the game never explains where magic
potion comes from but in later games
they are produced from chu jelly among
other things
although choo choos are not present in
ocarina of time they are found in
termina as his magic potion so
it's unlikely that the substance below
kakariko is the only way to obtain
magic however the possibility still
remains that this was the first time the
hylians and the shika first came into
contact with it with access to
replenishable magic the sheikah
subsequently created the lens of truth
and other magical artifacts which ran on
magic power
however the fact remained that the
unprocessed version of the liquid found
below the village had a
serious dark side to it be it during or
after the war the shika and royal family
may have realized that the undead
created in these morbid experiments
either served their purpose
or were hard to keep under control and
too dangerous to keep around as such
the entrances to these underground
crypts and chambers were sealed off
trapping the dead including bongo bongo
inside something which according to the
backstories impa
played a big role in here they remained
sealed away in darkness for what was
presumably intended to be all eternity
and the green energy remained
festering underground its fumes
continuing to rise filling the
underground caves and crips with its
dark influence
we're not done yet there is even more
evidence that the discoveries of the
chica made in kakariko's underground
were significant
something which advanced their
understanding of magic and technology in
this era
in several houses around hyrule books
with the famous chica eye symbol on it
can be found laying around
these include impasse house the
sculptula house
the medicine shop at hyrule castle town
granny's potion shop in kakariko village
the lakeside laboratory and lastly dampe
has one stashed away inside his shack as
well
as the symbol suggests these books were
clearly written by the shika
and since most of them were dead by the
end of the war they were probably
written before the war was over
aka during the time that these supposed
experiments and discoveries were taking
place
around kakariko village is it a
coincidence then that
both medicine potion shops in hyrule
have chica literature lying around
books written by the same tribe who
potentially discovered
and refined magic they aren't found in
any of the other establishments either
not the bazaar goron shop zora shop nor
the kohiri shop or any other house in
hyrule for that matter has one of these
books lying around
as for the other locations these books
are found these two make perfect sense
impa's house is pretty obvious of course
as she is a chica
the only still living member we know of
the lakeside laboratory makes sense too
since well it's a laboratory a place
where research is done
so naturally they would have books
written by the most advanced race in
hyrule
coincidentally the scientist working
here also happens to be the only person
in hyrule who knows that the spooky mask
which resembles the face of a re-dead is
made from an actual coffin
could be something that he learned from
the book as well how else would he know
such a specific detail
dampi being in possession of one of the
books seems a bit out of place at first
until you realize that he is literally
tending to a big part of lands that hide
the secrets below kakariko
being a pretty old guy and with access
to the shika writings
he was probably well aware of kakariko's
dark history
and some of the stuff that lay
underneath it this also explains why he
specifically chose the one grave he knew
had a giant network of caves inside it
as his final resting place
as well as the hiding place of his most
treasured possession the hook
shot lastly we have the sculptula house
this one isn't much of a surprise either
and may even explain the origin of the
curse cast upon the father and his five
sons who reside here
in the game it's never fully explained
where the spider curse came from
all we know is that it was the result of
their greed they are described and even
depicted as a family who was once very
rich
which suggests that the curse was cast
upon them due to their never-ending
desire for more wealth
but who's to say that this so-called
greed is referring to physical wealth
such as rupees
greed can come in many forms including
power
and since we find a shiga book covered
in cobwebs inside their house
it may very well be possible that they
were tampering with some other stuff
stuff related to the shika as it seems
a possible connection between the family
and the shika tribe can be found in the
shard of agony
previously known as the stone of agony
on the nintendo 64
it's a relic which can magically track
down hidden caves and grottos
and in the picture we can see one of the
brothers holding the shard as the family
proudly displays a fortune
hinting that the shard is what brought
them their riches in the first place
and here's the thing the shard of agony
too is rumored to be a shika artifact
just like the lens of truth it's also
made from a green crystal
another possible connection to the green
substance
it's never revealed how the family came
into possession of the shard of agony
but
what is clear is that their insatiable
cravings and greed for riches
by abusing the relic ultimately
backfired on them leaving them
mutated deformed and unable to leave
their abode for many years
yet another example of the dark forces
that come with shika-related objects
not to mention where have we heard a
reference to greed before
oh yeah the shadow temple here lies
hyrule's bloody
history of greed and hatred the hatred
part is pretty on the nose
what with the torture and killings and
all but the greed part could just as
well be referring to this
sought after magic power which led to
the experimentation the necromancy
construction of magic artifacts and
other dark practices
rather than the conquest for land and
power by the kingdom of hyrule
it's clear that during and after the war
some individuals like dampe
the potion makers the family of the
sculptureless house and another select
few gained access to the sheikah
writings
a product of their knowledge and
discoveries from the dark times at
kakariko village
knowledge which may have been passed on
from that moment
even all the way up to breath of the
wild
even if the green liquid is not at all
related to magic
potion specifically it could at least
still be possible that it is linked to
the rise of the dead
the curses hauntings and so on this
could also be a hint as to why
ganondorf's corpse refuses to die
completely
the forces at work here could be the
very same that created the first redeads
as ganondorf's body bears some strong
resemblances to the infamous undead
fearing his endless reincarnation
whoever put the seal on the demon cain
may have used the knowledge of spirit
magic to keep him from death
and instead froze his body in time
barely alive
yet with a faint but persistent
heartbeat
and that pretty much sums up the theory
there's a lot of what-ifs in this one
and it's pretty extensive too
covering multiple mysteries at the same
time but i hope i was able to pitch in
some new ideas
and of course be sure to share your
thoughts in the comments below so we can
get a good healthy discussion going
i would like to thank nintendo black
crisis for joining me in this video we
also worked on another video together on
his channel
in which we talk about some of the
biggest scams found in the zelda series
so if you like this video be sure to
give that one a watch too the link will
be in the description
and in the pinned comment a big thanks
as always goes to my gracious patreons
and members who continue to make my
content possible
and a joy to work on we've got quite a
lot of new faces since the last few
videos so if you will give a big
warm welcome to ketochi ian he
i cannot pronounce your last name kyle
marsh aaron hare
cornelius h belmont 10 north sora nelson
and isaac m dewitt how amazing of you to
join i cannot thank you all enough for
the support
anyway this has been a fun one and i
hope you found it entertaining i will
see you all in the next video this is
dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
you